autre phénomène intéressant la stabilité
du front national là où ses candidats se
sont maintenues au second tour le parti
de jean-marie le pen c'est ses meilleurs
scores dans le sud du pays et emportent
une mairie une seule celle de saint
gilles du gard
patrice volet l'école de saint gilles ce
matin a découvert la mairie à son
extrême droite pour 321 une voix le
front national a conquis l'écharpé
tricolore ici sécurité et immigration
sont depuis des années au coeur du débat
municipal avec près de 25% d'étrangers
sur 12000 habitants
j'ai jamais dit que je voulais prendre
les solutions draconiennes j'ai tout
simplement dit que je voulais trouver
des solutions ou même je suis un
descendant du général lafayette et je
connais parfaitement les terres de la
déclaration de l'homme puisque c'est des
droits de l'homme puisque c'est lui qui
l'a inspiré mais je crois aussi que
cette déclaration des droits de l'homme
comporte une partie très importante qui
sont et devoirs du citoyen monsieur le
maire c'est le versant aristocratique du
front national reconnu comme modéré très
fier d'une certaine ouverture sur sa
liste si rpr un émerger et 50% de
socioprofessionnels à saint gilles il
fait de la politique depuis à peine six
mois mais habite nîmes à 20 km
moi je pense qu'ils ont choisi l'image
du front national parce que les
solutions il y en a très peu qui a été
proposé par monsieur deux chambres
pendant cette campagne pour pas dire
pratiquement au pire donc je pense que
c'est plus de l'image du front national
qu'ils ont choisi et surtout le le
changement qu'ils ont évolué après une
campagne sans vagues saint gilles à
voter front national pour oublier les
divergences du précédent conseil
municipal udf rpr sans pour autant
savoir ce que le nouveau maire veut
faire de leur ville
difficile d'affirmer ce soir que saint
gilles sera pour six ans le laboratoire
des idées du front national
arnaud de chambrun semble tenir à
l'indépendance de sa liste mixte mais
ses adversaires politiques ici craignent
le poids des instances nationales du
front sur la vie locale